this is a short story of maybe the
quickest turnaround I've ever
experienced ever hear you're seeing a
very fine image made by the researcher
at stanford i'm not going to muck up her
name and i apologize please do see her
credit this is a solar voltaic device
that we decided to try to quickly get
attention for which was very exciting
research so they sent me a few of these
cells and I literally had just a few
hours to try to attempt an MIT home page
so i made an image of just one device i
actually used a stereomicroscope to make
the image but i could absolutely have
done the same with a camera and a 105
lens i just thought it would be
interesting for you to see this little
story even though i did not use a camera
and then I placed it in photoshop and
just duplicated a few of the layers just
to sort of get a feel for what I might
want to do and I wound up developing an
image with layers of the cells and move
them around I was in the mood for
lavender so but sure enough the MIT
office did use it on line but eventually
I was looking for the home page and
wanted to suggest something solar alike
so I used a gradient in the background I
really didn't like that and then I
remembered from my thousands of slides
of images of the landscape that I did in
fact have a sunset from California that
I took many years ago on film and so I
used that for the background overlaid
the various layers that I previously
made of the solar cell cropped it a
little bit and eventually they did in
fact use it for the MIT homepage this
all of I am not kidding three hours from
start to finish very unusual see if you
could do it I challenge you